eine illegale drogen party in hamburg es
ist die tür zu zimmer
716 im hotel auf der hamburger
reeperbahn das ist kein schmuddel hotel
hier ein vier sterne hotel das
doppelzimmer kostet immerhin 170 euro
und hier hinter dieser tür da hat sich
ein verbrechen abgespielt und
drogenexzess mit einem toten und einem
erst 13 jahre alten mädchen sandra was
genau geschah also hinter dieser
zimmertür 716
polizei kriminaltechnik spurensicherung
tütenweise tragen die beamten beweise
aus dem hotel suchen nach spuren und
antworten auf die frage was geschah in
zimmer 716
ich stehe hier vor allem vier sterne
hotel direkt an der reeperbahn
hier fand eine drogenparty ein
schreckliches ende ein 22 jähriger
junger mann starb am montag mieten fünf
hamburger personen das zimmer 716 des
arcotel onyx hotels vier erwachsene
männer im alter von 19 und 22 und ein 13
jähriges mädchen
der geplante aufenthalt vier tage doch
wie so ein hotel wenn alle in hamburg
leben unklar
mindestens drei der erwachsenen männer
und das 13 jährige mädchen sollen in
einem hotelzimmer wie diesem harte
drogen genommen haben bis in die frühen
morgenstunden soll die gruppe marihuana
alkohol
verschreibungspflichtige medikamente und
mutmaßlich kokain konsumiert haben ein
offensichtlich tödlichen drogencocktail
nach den jetzigen erkenntnissen sind
diese fünf personen in dem hotelzimmer
gewesen morgens in dem hotelzimmer haben
es dort schlafen gelegt und dann einer
von dem ein 20-jähriger mann ist dann
aufgewacht am späten abend späten
nachmittag war am späten nachmittag und
hat dann festgestellt dass eine person
die rettungskräfte sind unmittelbar vor
ort finden die leiche des 22 jährigen
aus dem bezirk hamburg stellingen doch
nicht nur das die drogen vergiften auch
die weiteren männer und das 13 jährige
mädchen schwer die notärzte müssen sie
ins krankenhaus bringen nach
bild-informationen lebt die 13 jährige
eigentlich in einer wohngruppe ist als
ausreißerin bekannt die ermittlungen
konzentrieren sich jetzt auf die
obduktion des 22-jährigen und auf drogen
die im zimmer gefunden worden doch viele
fragen sind noch offen was ist in diesem
zimmer mit dem 13 jährigen mädchen
geschehen welche rolle spielten die vier
männer die polizei ermittelt unter
hochdruck
[Musik]